what happened by your foreword Becky
search continues for for inmates who is
in federal custody this morning or you
say the men are armed and extremely
dangerous
let's go swimming know when you wait a
second what is she doing here you let
her walk all over you
she's 13 Jeff this gentleman lost his
dog okay well why don't you give us your
number dog is a Rottweiler purebred or
as the Germans call them or violent Mets
goons that's why you never let them meet
with other breeds you get the worst of
both okay I think it's time for you to
go I'm looking for a key it has this
symbol engraved on it you seen it no
well that leaves a little Becky where's
Becky wait wait he's gonna hold your dad
still I heard him I'm not gonna let them
get away with this
[Music]
and she was good she was very very good
when she was bad she was horrid
[Music]
what was the point of all this porky
trust much more than that okay you're
clearly a special girl
I don't want to have to hurt you but I
do want to hurt you real bad
[Music]
you